alive what's going on everybody he
realize that once again we are back on
the live show while probably recorded if
you're watching now my name is Tim Poe
I'm here with my buddy Adam hey
everybody we're done we're in Tahoe
what's going on we're talking about
silly nonsense okay it's not really
nonsense the lead story we have is about
a guy literally used a tinder date as
his getaway driver it's kind of off no
but I saved a bunch of it I'm not gonna
tell you because we save stuff that I
don't know anything but the title game
I'm gonna do this check this out
this is a book fact hunt by larry bundy
jr. it's really cool yeah [ __ ] that
this dude is a youtuber and his videos
are amazing and so he did this like he
did a book of all this crazy video game
history and trivia stuff that I bought I
just got it my name's in it I'm so
excited because it's a big list of
people who supported the book but his
channels really really awesome so Larry
Bundy jr. I think yeah it's a school
book you two just are recommending at me
as videos and I just started like
binging all of them oh yeah it's awesome
stuff learning about video games and
when we're not yeah so anyway I wanted I
want to give a shout out so I'm really
excited cuz it's a cool book so there
you go Larry awesome content so our
first story is about tinder again
Tinder's dangerous Panzers dude it's
it's scary man
so there's those crazy plays CNN is
reporting they met on a dating app then
he robbed a bank and their first on
their first date and forced her to be
the getaway driver oh man this guy has a
crazy what was this like it's it's one
of those things where you think it
sounds smart like I got an idea leopard
accomplice can you take me to the bank I
cheated on some money all right so
here's it's crazy withdrawal money but
I'm not gonna bury the lead on this one
check this out you think that's crazy
what if I told you first date from hell
woman forced to drive getaway car after
date commits robbery September 6th 2011
Wow it's going on for a woman in the UK
met a dude on Facebook and he made her
survey as her getaway driver
same story it's the same thing so we
thought it literally was the same story
yeah it's like it and so when the story
came up we were like wait I thought the
story was from 2020 yeah this is from
2011 we can't we can't talk about
oh it's is from 2020 oh wow this is new
it's happening again it happens a pear
it happens decently often I guess I
guess decently often insensate like
you'd never you don't really think of
this thing's gonna happen you know I
didn't think people robbed banks till
like I didn't know that was a thing and
I was actually looking at the dude you
got a districts and people robbing banks
you got to be dumb to rob a bank what
people are doing it you gotta be real
happening we're gonna get like 2 grand B
I said it's like it happens like 40
times a month in each state like a lot
of dumpy they have 40 like cases of it
and pretty much every different state
all across the states is happening
people robbing banks alright but here's
the other thing tinder is so dangerous
they've added a panic button to save
users from dangerous dates oh man but
like what are you gonna do and this is a
new story - like what are you gonna do
you're on a date and the guy's pointing
a gun or a knife you know in your
direction you're like little fun pull up
my phone and don't worry but I'm not
doing anything I'm not dialing 9-1-1 or
I'm on tinder or the awkwardness of like
pulling up tinder while you're on a date
yeah let me know wait I guess you go to
the bathroom or something but still it's
like oh give me one second then but then
you can call 9-1-1 just check my phone
real quick
are you tendering are you are you on
tinder right no no no if your date is
dangerous yeah why wouldn't you just
call the police
like I'm not gonna call the police I'm
gonna open tinder yeah why and hit the
panic button to let them call the police
probably and then what does it do what
is the let's let's do this let's learn
about let's learn about this lady who
was forced to be a getaway driver
because I guess you know look tenders
awful man let's let's read seenin
reports and you thought your for your
worst first date story was bad ha ha ha
that's so funny seeing a way to start it
up a Massachusetts woman became an
unexpected getaway driver after man she
met on a dating app robbed a bank on
their first date Christopher Castillo
the unnamed woman I don't know what
woman's would be Robin Hood why are they
praising the guy it's kind of like a
good thing at home yeah that's pled
guilty this week to armed robbery and
three counts of assault and battery on a
police officer I didn't get away with it
all committed on their first date on
December 5th 2016 according to the
Bristol County District Attorney's
Office is it weird that I'm a little
bummed you didn't get away with well how
is he supposed to get away with it I
don't know it's know that you got you
got to hear how dumb this guy liked it
as dumb as they come okay he was
sentenced to three years in state prison
for the robbery plus two years in the
Bristol County house
of Corrections for violently struggling
and spitting on police who tried to
subdue him according to the district
attorney's office the woman wasn't
charged the worst date ever story was
enough punishment now this is terrible
writing sounds like a patsy like if it
doesn't work you could just say that
right you know we but we met on tinder
what they did without doors that's
really provable true true yeah exactly
it's the perfect all right like yeah oh
yeah here and they even like set it up
so we can just link up on tinder so that
when you drive me there
that's your scapegoat I don't I don't I
don't know here's I don't buy no like in
the story the cops don't arrest the
chick the lady yeah that's weird
like if you're if you're a getaway
driver they're arresting you both well
let's ring then they'll find the story
out afterwards but still so that the
lady tells the police she picked him up
from his parents house go figure
in Rhode Island and drove in 30 minutes
east towards North Attleboro
Massachusetts
she said he drank wine in the passenger
seat of her Nissan Maxima which is also
illegal the two had never met in person
before that fateful day in 2016 told
police so why would she think anything
was wrong when he told her to pull over
as they approached a bank he got out of
her car and left her there alone for a
few minutes then suddenly he came
running back sweating with sunglasses a
hat a gun and $1,000 cash in hand the
woman the woman said effing go he told
her she panicked she told police so she
did as she was told the district
attorney's office fills in the blank
blanks on what happened next while she
was inside the bank
Castillo walked into the Bristol County
Savings Bank branch in North Attleboro
and showed a bank teller a gun he
demanded a thousand dollars and said he
needed it badly he was really hurting he
told the teller teller handed him the
money then he ran back out to his dates
Maxima in order to step on it his
accidental accomplice obeyed at first
but once she spotted flashing sirens
from North Attleboro police cruisers on
their tail she immediately pulled over
and walked away from their car
Castillo stayed inside and ducked from
police police pulled Castillo out of his
hapless date's car as he violently
struggled spit on them and told them his
gun wasn't loaded according to district
attorney's office after he was subdued
and handcuffed police searched the car
and found a 44 caliber gun an antique
belonging to his stepfather what
and a hat and sunglasses that match the
description of what the robber was
wearing
oh and that thousand dollars police
found that in Castillo's wallet years
after the date from hell Castillo ended
up sentenced to five years of car
serration his date got off without a
charge and probably with a healthy
skepticism toward online dating this was
some of the most cringe ewriting seen
and could ever done I could ever have
done I really I really hate this
narrative writing we like to do they
think they're being funny or you thought
your first date was terrible
I shouldn't bang that's kind of the joke
though no but you're right though it's
happened all the time I was reading some
people complaining about like how
recipes it's the same thing like there's
always the story about how oh yeah oh my
great grandfather your role is or I just
need the ingredients where are the angry
Oh finally read more oh there's the
ingredients like ah so III think she did
get arrested right but they probably
looked at her phone and we're like you
know get her out of here yeah the crazy
thing is when we when we found the story
it's basically the exact same thing that
happened in the UK late this this woman
meets a guy on Facebook he says let's go
on a date he tells her drive to the bank
then it says minutes later he ran it
with a knife in one hand in a bag of
money jumps in the car and screaming
drive drive drive
dude I'm willing to bet this happens
kind of often how are you trusting some
random person you've never met to be a
good driver I don't I don't like other
people driving me around you know I want
to be the person driver they're probably
thinking is funny one of the biggest
mistakes criminals make is involving
other people because it creates more
points of failure yeah you're right
they're probably thinking get a Rando to
do it they can tread on you right but
there they say the worst driver ever
it's like it's something that you think
sounds smart like there was one story I
read I don't think it sounds smart at
all I some guys get it at all there's a
story where a guy rubbed lemon juice on
his face okay yes and then went and
robbed a bank just with lemon juice on
his face where do you think it made him
invisible yes he thought because lemon
juice like was a component of invisible
ink that if you rubbed on his face the
cameras wouldn't see him yeah pretty
funny
yup these people are nuts but so we have
this story from a couple weeks ago
though tater at tinder titter ten
adding a panic button to save users from
dangerous dates because what they're
really trying to do is make you feel
better because people have been attacked
robbed and used as Patsy's and getaway
drivers because a panic button on tinder
is not gonna do anything to save anybody
no it's not I mean I guess if your dates
like I'm a dangerous person why don't
you open up tinder and swipe for me why
would that ever happen I don't know it
does it does it's let's we're making
assumption yeah I want to see what it
actually does yeah so the New York Post
says the popular hook-up app says it's
adding a panic button to help protect
users from frightening situations by
keeping tabs on their meeting times and
locations if they go about their dates
and summoning the authorities if called
the new opt-in feature will be offered
through a partnership with safety app
noon light and will be free to use the
company said on Thursday match group
which owns tinder will not have access
to any location information gathered by
noon light when a date is scheduled the
user will be able to share details with
the meetup with moonlight who will track
their location in real time using their
phones GPS if user triggers the panic
button they will receive a text from
noon light prompting them to enter a
code if they don't enter the code they
receive a call confirming the in
assistance if they confirm that they
need help or if they don't pick up noon
light summons authorities to do this
location oh that's that's so wonderful
think about it you're on a bad day this
is hope it's so brilliant you know to
bed date and you're like oh man this guy
is really dangerous let me press the
panic button and then they get tax you
don't answer and then the phone rings
and he says who's calling you answer it
and then you answer it is I put it on
speaker and you put on speaker
tell him everything's fine everything's
okay great click well that's scary
sounds like it's a pointless stupid P
arsenal I mean we were saying earlier
it's like well what are they gonna do
what is it gonna end up being because
all I would want to do is call the
authorities and they I mean it is it's
trying to be like a silent way to do
that but you know you still have to pick
up your phone and you still have to look
here's the problem if you're feeling
like it's dangerous you just call 9-1-1
boom 9-1-1 you can't do either of those
things well I mean it's gonna be faster
than you know going into the end of
crossing you're always finding tinder
hitting tune your opening tinder you
gotta wait for know probably like press
that
you meup and masky or something I don't
know yeah maybe it's like a widget or
he's not gonna be able to do either
these things the problem is people that
you're responsible and they're meeting
up with strangers on the Internet and we
were told all the time when we were
younger not to meet strangers like don't
get into a stranger's car and now we're
like I found a stranger on the Internet
can you pick me up I'm attracted to this
stranger I'm gonna get in his car right
you're right it is kind of crazy we've
been taught our whole lives like don't
trust people you don't know and we don't
know anybody that's on the Internet yeah
the stupidest no people in our circles
that's what it is the stupidest there's
two really stupid things I find out I
find really really stupid about online
dating okay
the first are people who are like I'll
meet you anywhere for any reason it's
like I won't that's that's really dumb
yeah like what if you're nuts
yeah I'll meet you during the day in a
public place right Starbucks and I could
walk away from you
exactly and everyone will see me walking
away from and and well I mean if you're
if you live in the middle of nowhere
it's a lot harder but you still find
there's my right there's malls you can
go to let's walk around Walmart there's
a Walmart everywhere but here's here's
the other dumb thing about online dating
is the people who are the opposite like
I won't meet you unless I know for sure
it's like dude hold on wait a minute
you're an online dating app to meet
people and you're like we got to talk
for three months before I'm oh well then
don't waste my time well there's there's
FaceTime like people people do that
don't say like well let's let's FaceTime
first just to see if we can get get a
vibe I guess right I don't know that
makes sense more than just meeting up
randomly yeah you know what Starbucks I
I obviously the head gender I use tender
a little bit back in the day and like I
met a few people the problem with that I
found with it is you can't you don't get
that that energy you you can't feel
someone's energy even if you FaceTime
home you get with them you get the
energy of them that you know it's like
you got to know if you vibe with
somebody you know and that any way that
you feel you know see it online you know
it's all it's all their best pictures
it's all their their best face let's
that's all online dating yeah I know
exactly and you don't bumble it yeah
yeah bumble do you think it's better you
know it works only women can message
yeah yeah okay I just think it's all
dumb it's all it's all gimmick to get
you to try to go in
different direction you're the problem
one of the things one of things I find
online dating there's no difference one
of the most annoying things about
today's dating landscape with like you
know we've talked about the Gillette
commercial the other day where the guys
gonna go talk to them and the guys like
don't do that whoa it's really annoying
because now you basically have a whole
bunch of dudes spam messaging women
right and so it's literally just static
noise yeah basically so it's like I just
don't even find a point I'm not gonna
waste my time yeah eventually it just
becomes more generic you know our know
go to the supermarket okay what are
these what do they say if you want to
meet if you want a one-night stand you
go to a bar if you want a wife you go to
a supermarket is that I've never heard
that saying the the point is that people
who are out at bars looking for a good
time okay regular people are doing
chores the supermarket all right so if
you're at the market and you see I could
you know young women or whatever you
spoke up a conversation whoa whoa whoa
but that's toss toxic masculine it's
right exactly that's lining about that
no so apparently I well we have another
story this is this from November of last
year tinder is is like tailors robberies
right now attenders a dangerous app man
that you know it was like it I mean look
I'm sure 90% of people just do their
stupid you know
tinder whatever it is you know they hook
up and they peace out
hey Family Guy did a really funny
episode with quagmire okay and he goes
to he goes to meet a woman for a date
off tinder and he brings flowers and
he's like I brought you flowers and
she's like okay take off your pants and
get on the sink and he's like really and
she goes yeah and they finish and he's
like do I have to take you out to dinner
and she's like what for your clothes put
your clothes back on by and she like
walks away and then it basically turns
into him being like Gollum from Lord of
the Rings okay and he's like swiping and
I'll like disheveled and like others
scraggly people are come to this house
but but but no I there's something funny
about these apps like uber and tinder
and whatever whatever else they are
aware and tinder yes uber and tinder
okay where we basically pull up our
phone and say connect me with a stranger
someone I've never met before I'm just
crossing my fingers open they're not
going to use me as a getaway driver or
rob me because we have this wit like
listen this this story it says 14
suspected in tinder robberies near
uw-oshkosh arrested and charged it was
not hard to find this story literally
Google tinder danger and it's like 800
thousand stories pop up for it's like
your home I goods are young right it's
like never robbery never been easier to
meet up with strangers who are
unsuspecting morons I think it all ties
back into Millennials being like stunted
children and I just mean the dudes I
mean the chicks too like parents have
just plowed away all the obstacles so
they're like everything safe and then
you hear these stories about women who
are like I'm gonna go to Tajikistan and
ride my bike and then guess what happens
yet you know gone this is the first time
that I've felt you know that videogames
may have started to mess with kids Minds
like I played video games my whole life
I I like video games I've never wanted
to rob a bank you know I play Grand
Theft Auto that's not video games - I
may be a [ __ ] well why do they think
they can get away with it so easily
because you know their dads I don't know
mom sure there's real no no I'm sure
that is you know but then there's you
know they're like Grand Theft Auto five
you're robbing all these different banks
that's basically the whole premise of
it's just real like no I know it's not
real but it's not gonna nah that's
that's that's like yeah I'm just I'm
just saying this is the first time I've
like that little inkling of thought
popped in my head I'm like maybe studies
show that the studies have all shown
there's no correlation now good well
that's the idea but but well you know
pennant Penn & Teller did this really
funny thing where they gave a little kid
a pot like the Adam do koto shooting
range and fire powerful rifle okay was
really great at first-person shooters
okay cried he cried he cried after
firing I think it was a three-round
pulse uh-huh yeah I cried and then he
started crying and they were like this
kid how are you like 12 or 13 let's
young started crying like he was like
terrified of it yeah video games are
very very they're powerful man now I'll
tell you what like there's there there
are some benefits you get out I learned
how to drive playing like NASCAR what is
it was that game yeah a rage racer there
you go Ridge Racer for a Sega Saturn and
so I really learned to drive yeah in the
arcade uh-huh and then the first time I
drove I was like hey is not you know the
first the first time I would get my
license I didn't do driver's ed or
anything I the first time I drove in a
car was when I was literally getting
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. sometimes an hour or
two and we do have a full live recorded
version of the show that includes a lot
of comments and smaller segments you
probably don't see if you want to check
that out you can watch live at 8 p.m.
Monday through Friday or become a member
of this channel and for five bucks a
month you get full access to all of the
recorded podcasts every day after the
show we make them available in the
community section of this YouTube
channel so don't forget to subscribe and
stick around for more segments and more
shows Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you